i i do feel guilty about it because  there's so many super fans who should be  in it however  this was a makeup for uh  a buddy of mine joe derosa who could  give a [ __ ] about sports and i remember  like 10 years ago  he came up to me you know he's always  squinting right he was just like yeah  you know bill i was in a bar the other  night and uh i had drinks with this guy  he was somehow connected with the  yankees uh i forget his name it was uh  and i was immediately looking at him  like he got to be [ __ ] man he's just it  was like joe joe terry  and i was like joe tori  he's like yeah yeah that was the guy i  go you had [ __ ] drinks with joe torre  he was like yeah he's like is he uh  is he a big guy in in the yeah and i  just i had to walk away  so  i ended up calling him and i said joe  did i ever tell you about the time i met  george lucas and he goes you  [ __ ] and i said joe i'm living  your dream go [ __ ] yourself when i hung  up on